[Music]  on this mountainous Hillside in eastern  Java I'm surrounded by hundreds if not  thousands of coffee plants coffee has  been associated with Indonesian history  and economics for a long time yet  there's a crisis Brewing here  environmental change is decreasing the  crop and diluting the coffee and young  Javanese would rather go to college in  big cities than work the land as their  forebears have Java without its namesake  drink it's not out of the question there  aren't easy solutions Farms could move  to higher and cooler ground but that  land has to be bought you can't just  March into it there's a role for science  here let's try to develop more climate  resistance strains of coffee given the  popularity of the drink at the start of  many people's day why not develop a  reserve of beans equivalent to their  strategic petroleum Reserve in the U.S  or an IMF of caffeine you don't want top  decision makers to be without their  morning fix for too long  [Music]